>> Okay Michael, so here's the quiz, because you made me
make it a quiz, I decided to make it even harder, so
I want you to tell me how many different strategies are
there for A and how many different strategies there are for B.
>> And you are talking about just deterministic mappings only, right?
>> Well, we are in a two player
zero sum, finite, deterministic game of perfect information.
>> So, [LAUGH].
>> So yes, I mean deterministic.
>> Okay, alright. because, you know, it could be that it might be helpful
to be stochastic.
>> Oh, that's true, that's true. So in fact, that's
a good point. I was going to mention that later, but
l'll mention it now. What I just wrote down here, is
actually not just a strategy, it's something called a pure strategy.
>> Hm, it's always about purity with you.
>> It is, purity of chocolate and bacon mainly. But, yes. So, these are
simple pure strategies. Okay, so how many pure strategies are there for A and B.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, then let's go.